unser wahl eli der kreis heute über ganz
deutschland und wie das dann genau
ausschaut er hat uns vorher eine
nachricht geschickt bevor er an den
start gegangen ist der hubschrauber ist
mittlerweile in der luft damit sie einen
überblick bekommen über diese
komplizierte situation wird über diesen
spannenden tag hier in deutschland und
er hat uns vorher diese nachricht noch
geschickt
die reporter sind heute im ganzen land
unterwegs wir wollen überall wissen was
die menschen sagen und wie sie auf diese
wahl blicken und mit dem bild heli sind
wir auch über dem land unterwegs wir
blicken auf worte die heute wichtig sind
die im wahlkampf wichtig waren und am
abend kreisen wir natürlich auch über
berlin über der hauptstadt wo am ende
der bundestag zusammen kommt und einen
neuen kanzler wählt unser ziel ihnen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer alles
zeigen was deutschland heute bewegt
der build life ball hinkommt
im himmel über deutschland der action
reiste wahltag rekord
[Musik]
er ist abgehoben und wir schalten direkt
jetzt mal zu unserem wahl healey und
unserem reporter im heli sebastian prill
sebastian wo seid ihr gerade
die hausbank
bei dem parteitag
an
der kameramann der zeigt uns dass jetzt
einmal
schmeckt einmal herum
ja und wenn man sich da sollte man so
ein schöner tag man kann sich das so gar
nicht gut
wenn ich
und die waldmenschen die
dem erteilt haben
da wird heute für
die darum trocknung und
gespannt sein
dank die verbindung ist nicht ganz so
gut der ton natürlich da oben im
helikopter also er seit über dem aartal
da wo die flut katastrophe passiert ist
wo 180 menschen ums leben gekommen sind
und wir ändern uns noch an die bilder
der überfluteten landschaften dort wo
wirst du heute noch hinfliegen
wir fliegen heute
erstmal weiter hier über das teil dann
werden wir gleich dabei seit den jahren
wenn armin laschet seine stimme abgeben
wird und dann wird der ball die weiter
fliegen nach berlin natürlich in die
hauptstadt wichtig war heute abend
entscheiden wir werden überall da nah
dran sein
heute wichtige entscheidungen fallen
werden
ein spannender tag vor uns du lieferst
uns den überblick im wahrsten sinne des
wortes und wir werden den ganzen tag
über immer wieder in denen bild wahl
heli schalten
[Musik]